An extended Disney princess scene, cameos
by Kylo Ren and the Golden Girls, plus more
Fix-It Felix and Calhoun are just some of
the many scenes cut from Ralph Breaks The
Internet.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing everything that was
deleted from the Wreck-It Ralph sequel including
some incredible cameos and jokes you may wish
had been in the movie!
Keep watching to the end to find out the amazing
extended Stan Lee scene that didn't make it
in to the final film.
My Funko Pops giveaway is also running on
this video, so hit the bell and tap the Gleam
link in the video description to enter.
Mild spoilers ahead, though I've kept them
to a minimum, and there are no spoilers for
the ending.
The Disney princess team-up in Ralph Breaks
The Internet is one of the movie's highlights,
however, originally the scene played out rather
differently.
In early versions of the story, Vanellope,
Ralph and Yesss were all at OhMyDisney together
and saw the princesses greeting fans there.
Yesss gave Vanellope a tour of the Disney
fan site and Stormtroopers escorted the princesses
backstage where Vanellope followed them.
Footage shown at Disney's D23 Expo in 2017
also revealed several extra jokes cut from
the final film.
For example, Jasmine was allergic to cats
and her pet tiger Rajah looked at her slightly
offended as she puffed on an inhaler.
And Snow White always looked surprised because
she was secretly "legally blind" and needed
a pair of thick glasses.
C-3PO also originally had an extended scene
with the princesses after he arrived in the
green room to tell them there was another
"Which Disney princess are you?"
quiz about to start.
In the deleted footage, Cinderella replied,
"why thank you R2-D2" and the other princesses
joined in poking fun at him.
Sleeping Beauty told Cinderella that the Star
Wars droid "hates [being] called that", but
then trolled him with the line "we'll be right
there, BB-8!"
C-3PO, feeling mortally offended, walked out
mumbling, "Such insolence.
'You're good with princesses,' they said.
'You'll love this job.'
… Oh, how I long for the days of Captain
Solo."
These extended jokes were probably deleted
to create better comedy timing in the scene
and better pacing in the movie overall, but
I wonder whether the C-3PO jokes ended up
being trimmed because some Star Wars fans
were disappointed that their iconic Princess
Leia didn't appear in the scene.
The Wreck-It Ralph 2 filmmakers decided to
only use so-called "canonized" Disney Princesses
from the "official" Disney line for the scene,
excluding various other princesses from Disney
animated movies and Disney-owned properties
like Star Wars.
They did, however, add Elsa, Anna and Moana
who aren't part of the official princess line-up,
but they are hugely popular and it's rumoured
they'll be joining the official list soon.
By the way, Vanellope taking selfies with
the princesses doesn't appear in the movie
either, though it's unclear if that's part
of a scene cut from the film or a moment just
created for marketing.
Just before Vanellope and the Disney princesses
meet, there was going to be another extended
Star Wars crossover scene.
After the Hoodie Princess gets accused of
peddling unauthorised clickbait at OhMyDisney,
she escapes from the Stormtroopers and, in
an extended version of this scene, Vanellope
jumped onto Dumbo and flew off with the little
elephant while getting chased by TIE fighters.
In the final movie, the Star Wars chase is
stripped right back and shows Vanellope fleeing
on foot from the Stormtroopers before cutting
straight to her glitching into the princess
room backstage.
Another scene we never saw involved a joke
at the expense of Star Wars baddie Kylo Ren.
LucasFilm objected to how he was going to
be portrayed in the animated movie.
Co-director Rich Moore explained there was
a joke "about Kylo Ren being kind of a spoiled
child" but after they took it to LucasFilm
to show them what they were doing "they said
[…] well, we'd prefer that you don't show
him [like that].
You know, he is our villain, and we'd prefer
you don't do that."
It seems a shame this Kylo Ren cameo got cut
as the jokes in Ralph Breaks The Internet
are generally gentle jibes that affectionately
parody characters from Disney's broad range
of properties.
And I imagine the Kylo Ren joke would've got
quite a few laughs especially as the Star
Wars villain certainly has form when it comes
to acting out like a spoiled child.
It's also possible that, with the current
Star Wars trilogy about to complete in Episode
9, LucasFilm were concerned the joke might
cause some kind of problem for where they're
taking Kylo Ren in their next movie.
A Star Wars-inspired character, Double Dan,
who has a Jabba the Hutt-style appearance,
also had an additional scene deleted.
When Ralph goes to the Darknet with Spamley,
he meets the half-human half-worm character
[Double Dan] and the second head he has living
in his neck.
"Yeuk!"
"What are you doing here?"
"The reason I came to your neck of the face."
"I mean there's a face in your neck!"
"Ha ha, I mean woods, neck of the woods!"
Originally, there was going to be a "Lady
and the Tramp" moment where we see the two
Dans eating a virus together, and just like
that iconic spaghetti and meatballs scene,
the two Dans end up kissing.
There's a stack of Disney cameos in the movie's
OhMyDisney scenes, but originally the four
lead characters from the popular 80s sitcom
The Golden Girls were also going to make an
appearance.
The idea for these cameos came when the filmmakers
were researching the real-life OhMyDisney
website and noticed The Golden Girls featured
heavily there.
However, during early screenings of Wreck-It
Ralph 2, some people were confused about why
Blanche, Rose, Dorothy and Sophia were in
the scene and so they ended up being cut from
the film.
Although the hit sitcom aired on NBC it was
produced by Disney and the four actresses
received Disney Legends awards in 2009, so
it is a real shame they didn't make it into
the movie.
In fact, co-director Phil Johnston has said
it's one of his biggest regrets.
Although fan favourite Tinkerbell did make
a very brief appearance in Wreck-It Ralph
2 when Vanellope rushed past her backstage
at OhMyDisney, originally, Disney's best-known
fairy had a larger role in the movie.
In footage shown at D23, there was a scene
where "Tinker Bell tickles Ralph's nose until
he insults her by calling her 'Stinker Smell'."
This might have been a fun little moment,
so I imagine it was cut simply because the
filmmakers changed the story and Ralph no
longer accompanied Vanellope on her visit
to OhMyDisney.
Fans of Fix-It Felix and Calhoun may be a
little disappointed that the pair got a much
smaller part in the sequel, although they
did get to deliver some hilarious perfect
parenting advice that none of us will ever
know the truth about!
But the original story envisioned a much bigger
role for the couple as during the second act
we would have seen how the pair were coping
with trying to bring up a horde of unruly
racers.
The way this was initially going to happen
was that there was going to be another character
in the movie called Bev, who was not only
the head of an antivirus company but was also
a secret villain who was tracking what Ralph
was doing on the internet which led her to
the arcade.
By returning to the arcade midway through
the movie, we would have got more screen time
with Felix and Calhoun, but once the Bev anti-virus
plot was dropped, of course, that didn't happen.
It does feel like the duo's story was a touch
abbreviated with something missing in the
middle, but at least now we know why it feels
like that.
The Pancake-Milkshake scene was an instant
hit when it debuted in the film's first trailer,
and originally it was supposed to appear in
the main part of the movie with Ralph and
Vanellope visiting the game when they were
loot-hunting.
"Woh.
Games!"
"Out of my way kid."
"Pancake.
Milkshake."
"Milkshake.
Huh.
I'm starting to understand why people like
this game."
"Eat, eat!"
"Err, Ralph you might wanna try feeding the
kitty for a little while."
"No!
The kitty gets the milkshake, the bunny gets
the pancake..."
In fact, this scene was one of the first ideas
to be fully animated.
However, as the story developed, the directors
felt that Ralph and Vanellope's loot-hunting
activities were dragging out too long so they
deleted the scene and went straight to Slaughter
Race instead to move the plot forward more
quickly.
The problem was that, at that point, Disney
had already started commissioning production
of Funko Pops, plushes, and other toys for
the bunny and the cat.
Fortunately, co-writer and director Phil Johnston
came up with the idea of keeping the scene
as a mid-credits stinger and turning it into
a deliciously meta-joke.
Funnily enough, Johnston's fellow Wreck-It
Ralph 2 director Rich Moore has confessed
that he's exactly the kind of person who goes
crazy when a trailer scene doesn't show up
in the film he's watching.
I wonder if he's also the kind of person who
likes watching deleted scenes videos on YouTube!
By the way, I reveal how Ralph Breaks The
Internet trolls all us Disney, Marvel and
Pixar fans in my other video, which I'll add
links to at the end, and in the video description.
While developing the first Wreck-It Ralph
movie, Disney managed to secure the rights
to include Mario and Luigi from the Super
Mario games.
In the end, though the filmmakers couldn't
find a good way to include the famous video
game characters in the movie, however, Rich
Moore did state that he wanted Mario to appear
in the sequel.
Sadly, though by the time the sequel entered
development, the rights were no longer available
to Disney, meaning everyone's favourite Italian
plumber couldn't appear in Ralph Breaks The
Internet.
Marvel Comics legend Stan Lee passed away
shortly before the release of the Wreck-It
Ralph sequel, making his brief appearance
in the film a particularly poignant moment
for Marvel fans.
And it's especially sad that originally a
much longer extended scene was planned for
the comic-book superstar.
An earlier version of Lee's cameo featured
a device called the Marvelizer where avatars
for net users would transform into a Marvel
character after walking through a machine
that looked similar to a metal detector.
Stan Lee would also have walked through the
machine, but unfortunately when the scene
ended up on the cutting room floor we never
got to see which Marvel character Disney thought
Stan Lee was.
Marvel fans will know there's a theory that
Stan Lee's cameos in the MCU mean he's a character
known as Uatu the Watcher and I wonder whether
we might have seen that theory confirmed.
Now, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
and cameos were in the final film?
Let me know in the comments below and remember
to subscribe and click on the gleam link in
the video description for a chance to win
an awesome Wreck-It Ralph Funko Pop.
Tap left to check out every secret easter
eggs you missed in the Disney Princess scene
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like!
Congrats to the winners of my Grinch giveaway!
Send me an email with your details so I can
get your prizes sent out to you.
And if you enjoyed this, remember to share
and leave a thumbs-up for more videos like
this.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!